[Music]
we are totally obsessed with nois
Antonio who plays heartthrob Peter
Kaminsky and to all the boys I've loved
before but did you know he was almost
cast in another hit movie keep watching
to find out which movie almost starred
our beloved Noah let it keep up with all
the latest hit movies and TV shows make
sure to hit the subscribe button for
more awesome content that we should meet
like this off
hey Netflix has gotten into the teen
rom-com genre recently and they are on
point we just know some of these new
movies are gonna go down in Hollywood
history has some of the best teen movies
ever it felt like forever since Netflix
teased us with to all the boys I've
loved before when it finally came out
August 17th 2018 we were not
disappointed we don't even want to tell
you how many times we've watched it
since then to all the boys I've loved
before is absolute perfection
we love that in the age of movies
without representation this movie is
about an Asian American girl go Netflix
for giving us some diversity and they
cast this movie perfectly the movie
stars
Lana Condor as Lara Jean Kobe she's
pretty shy when it comes to boys but she
writes letters to the boys she's been in
love with she never sends them though
and keeps them in a box in her closet
but then all her letters mysteriously
get mailed to these boys how
embarrassing if something like that
happened to us we would crawl into a
hole and never come out Laura Jean is
terrified because the boy she's
currently in love with is her sister's
boyfriend uh-oh can you say complicated
sisters before misters right enter Peter
Kavinsky played by the totally handsome
Noah Santonio hashtag swoon Peter was
Laura jeans first kiss back in eighth
grade in high school he got super
popular he plays lacrosse and is
apparently the most handsome of all the
handsome boys according to Laura Jean
he's
reeling from a crazy dramatic breakup so
when he gets Lord genes letter he sees
an opportunity Laura Jean and Peter
enter a fake relationship so her sister
won't feel like Laura Jean betrayed her
this movie has everything we love love
triangles fake relationships and
relatable characters obviously Peter is
just so perfect that Laura Jean ends up
falling in love with him while they
pretend to date it's rom-com perfection
plus there are more books in the series
so it's totally possible we'll get more
of these characters hey y'all ready nois
Antonio is the perfect star into all the
boys I've loved before we can't imagine
anyone else playing him and now we're
totally obsessed Noah was born in 1996
the Miami born actor has been around
Hollywood for a few years he moved to
Los Angeles when he was 16 but he
actually started acting before that in
2010 he starred in the family film the
gold retrievers where he and his dog go
in search of some treasure to save his
family it's so adorable and Noah's
performance proved that he's crazy
talented he starred in another kid's
movie called turkle's in 2011 before he
started getting some small Disney
Channel roles that's right
Noah Santonio is another Disney Channel
discovery they sure know how to
recognize Talent
he made appearances on Austin and Ally
shake it up and Jesse he became a well
known name after he played the popular
jock in the Disney Channel Original
Movie how to build a better boy where he
starred opposite China and McClain this
launched him into much bigger TV roles
including the Fosters on freeform he
played hey-zeus adams-foster
and he proved to the world that he could
play serious roles too Noah is super
relatable he did a fun tell-all
interview with BuzzFeed who we just fell
in love with him
he loves taco bell for comfort food Sam
Noah totes am his first celeb crush was
Cameron Diaz he wants to go to Cuba and
he starred in Camila Cabello Havana
music video he loves playing teen love
interests because he says he's a
hopeless romantic same Noah totes same
and the best part is he says he's
absolutely open to playing Peter in any
sequels
what other movie was Noah Santonio
supposed to be in well he auditioned for
another Netflix rom-com that is super
popular the kissing booth
crazy right can you imagine if someone
else had played Peter Kavinsky into all
the boys of love before we sure can't
and we are so glad the kissing booth has
the cast that it does because it is
perfect if you haven't seen the kissing
booth you're missing out this movie is
totes adorbs it stars the awesome cast
of joey king jacob oh lordy and Joel
Courtney Joey plays el who's in love
with her best friend's brother Noah Noah
is the most popular guy in school
and he always seems to treat el as a
little sister el and her bestie li have
grown up together and they have all
these friendship roles one of them not
dating each other's family things get
complicated when Noah and L kiss at a
fundraiser kissing boo
they end up sneaking around with in a
secret relationship which causes all
sorts of drama with lead it's got the
sweetest scenes and the best part is
Joey king and Jacob oh lordy are a
real-life couple their chemistry is on
fire that's part of the reason we can't
imagine Noah Santonio playing Noah in
the kissing booth
you just can't replicate the kind of
chemistry the two main characters have
but can you imagine if Noah sent an ale
have been cast do you think he would
have ended up dating Joey King in real
life we wonder if we would have ever
heard of Jacob lordy is there some sort
of alternate universe where Jacob plays
Peter Kaminsky into all the boys I've
loved before we're having trouble
imagining this scenario thankfully
everything is right with the Netflix
universe and the stars are in their best
roles you could say the stars aligned if
you want more Noah sent a nail like we
do you can catch him on another Netflix
rom-com on September 7th 2018 he stars
in Ciara Burgess is a loser he's a hot
jock who starts texting the wrong girl
but he falls for her while thinking
she's the most popular girl in school so
the main character and the popular girl
team up to help each other out it looks
so good we cannot wait in the meantime
we guess we'll just keep watching to all
the boys I've loved before and the
kissing booth on repeat until the new
movie comes out are you as pumped about
Ciara Burgess is a loser
we are do you think nois Antonio would
have been good in the kissing booth
don't be shy like Laura Jean Kobe let us
know in the comments so that's the movie
that nois Antonio was almost cast in
instead of to all the boys I've loved
before keep up with all the hit movies
here by hitting that subscribe button
see you next time
[Music]